In Pakistan, a top Karachi police chief known for campaigning against the Taliban...
...has been killed in a bomb blast.
In Tunisia, Islamist Prime Minister Ali Larayedh is set to resign...
...in order to end months of political deadlock in the country.
More than 13,000 families have fled Fallujah,...
...as NGOs warn of a dire humanitarian situation in Iraq.
In Chad, African leaders begin talks...
...to address sectarian violence in the Central African Republic.
In Germany, the government says it has accepted a UN request...
...to destroy remnants of Syria's chemical weapons on its own soil...
...as part of a bid to eliminate the arsenal by June 30.
And finally from Thailand, thousands of protesters march through Bangkok...
...to drum up support for a planned shutdown of the city next week.